I'm very excited for Adele that this is
her feature directorial debut I have
High Hopes there are going to be many
more movies for her to come so can you
each tell me something about her as an
actor's director that you appreciated
and that you're excited for more actors
to get to experience on her future films
I think Adele really celebrated our
writers and also really protected her
actors and I think the reason why this
film works is because it's not only
insane and chaotic and raunchy but she
did a really
um intensive effort in protecting the
heart of the story between these friends
and also this woman Audrey trying to
find her birth mother yeah I second that
it's really like it shows that she had
obviously worked in TV as a writer
because like she was so so specific
about like what the emotional journeys
of each character were and making sure
it was like plotted through and like
carried out and well executed so I'll
stick with my serious stuff before
getting to all the outrageous things you
both do in this movie
um first I love when people give each
other flowers so can you each tell me
about a time on this set when a KOA a
co-star just like blew your mind took
something that was on the page made
something like way more anything
different than what you expected with it
and you want to say good job to them I
remember watching on the monitor the
scene between Audrey and Lolo Ashley and
Sherry Cola
um when Ashley's in her cheap haul and
she's talking about like wow if I had
gone to Asia sooner if I had maybe I
would have like seen myself differently
all throughout High School I would have
not needed to be you know just the Asian
one but I could be the smart one or the
kind and funny one I remember watching
that scene on a monitor and it was so
beautiful and completely like not what
we had been doing in the movie and I
just remember really feeling the heart
of the film in that moment and I just I
love that scene I think it's the balance
of heart and laughs in this movie is
what makes it so special I love it have
it for you I was filled with rage seeing
how good that all three of you were
improvising like I remember watching
like the slapping gets kind of edited
down to a very quick thing but there was
like so much electric like magic
happening between like Stephanie and
Sherry it was like a little gay it was
it was awesome there's a whole like gay
track between uh um Sherry's character
and my character that kind of got edited
and will be saved for the sequel but
Sherry's a little bit about it yeah I
know it needs to happen in a sequel or
something but it's just everyone is so
quick and like some of those like quick
like off the cuff jokes like you know
you know the movie is so joke dense and
it's like of course it's the writers but
it's also the actors who are just like
on fire sometimes it is really scary to
me
should I quit comedy level scary I have
so many follow-up questions for both of
you right now I'll go to the first thing
that crossed my mind the slapping it can
for any actor out there who is about to
do their first on-screen slap scene can
you give them one do and one don't for
doing like a million believable slaps so
definitely don't actually slap them
however I can't I can't 100 confirm that
I did not actually slap Sherry I don't
really know how we did that we must have
you know mimed it but
and I'm like trying I feel like a graze
happened at one point yeah don't slap
your actual actor yeah
Sabrina for you I like I know you just
said you were in awe of their improv
abilities but like everything you do in
this movie is something else and I know
it's your first feature and that is very
much something special and to be
celebrated here again for you I think
there's going to be many more things on
the horizon so what is something you
experience on your first feature that
you really appreciated and helped you
deliver your best work that you hope to
experience on more films in the future
oh it was genuinely like like the cast
of the creators gave me so much like
space I think I think partially because
there was this feeling of like this
project is very special it's like a
first of its kind like for a lot of us
it was a first in one way or another
like Ashley's first feature film two I
think as a lead and like Tyrann Teresa's
first film
I it felt like we were on a group
project like no one was there just to be
like I'm here to work and like and and
so I had so many questions didn't know
like what coverage was like how to
advocate for myself and and I felt very
much like Stephanie and Sharon Ashley
were like family and always checking in
with me and like I just would not be
able to give the takes that I gave if it
weren't for them you know I'd be like oh
yeah you like that um I feel terrible
but yeah you know the best and you know
it was good to just feel like I could
say what I thought was funny and like
try and yeah whatever you get what I'm
saying great great success with this
spell I mean both of you this entire
ensemble is something else a silly
question it doesn't really apply to your
characters but I brought it up in the
other rooms now I want to know your
opinions on this also I tell you what an
acting Would You Rather game alive and a
question I love asking there's a vomit
scene in the movie that's my excuse to
ask this would you rather have to fake
vomit or fake sneeze in a scene oh
wait somebody fill me in is fake
sneezing a hard thing is that that's
that's why I compare it to like vomit
sounds gross but I mean I don't know how
someone would believably do a fake
sneeze on yes sir
fake vomit that sounds so fun to puke on
you
that sounds I think it's somebody who
was puked on and left in the basement to
wonder if we moved on I was like I can't
deliver that pain to another person we
did reshoots I mean I had gotten puked
on so many times yeah and um
it's like it's actually just like nice
smelling oats and stuff but it truly I
will never forget what it was like
walking around set and seeing everyone
look at me like this
hurtful to my core I was like what's
wrong with me that's why vomit always
feels like the wrong answer because like
it's fake but it genuinely grosses me
out I'm not a freaking ass
I have to ask about one other scene that
I absolutely adore in this movie tell me
absolutely everything about filming like
I don't know what you guys refer to
refer to it as but the cocaine train
scene is something like that as chaotic
for you on set as it plays for us in the
final film okay I thought it was
actually very chaotic it was chaotic
yeah it was really like accepting like
Sabrina's gonna stick this in my butt
come on come on guys
hey camera guy yeah yeah right there
okay yeah that is an absolutely
brilliant scene of everything you do and
say in this movie what is like the one
thing where on set when you deliver the
line or whatever it was that made you
think there's absolutely no way they're
gonna let this get into the finished cut
and now it is in the final song that
everyone will say
oh
okay I think our pause is because there
are so many things that I'm like dancing
like that genius line we you're right
that was too crazy which one oh you can
say it we have an audience filled of
adults
uh uh
I mean there's a whole park that
there's also I mean the Gay's laughing
I'm so sad is gone well there's one
thing that Sherry Cola does that I can't
believe is not only in the film I mean I
can't believe it's in the film but I
can't believe it made it to the trailer
which is like
she's like oh you sure you don't they're
talking about sex and she's like you
sure you don't miss it because you seem
a little tense from all the no boning
and then she goes and she doesn't she
just does a really grotesque oh I think
that's awesome okay I think it's amazing
I just can't believe it's in the trailer
I think it's um the really
um detailed um sound you get during the
sex Montage where you're like wow I am
really hearing
the Foley artist is going too hard on
this moment I can't believe
um well I hope that guy wins an Oscar
can I speak that into existence yeah
like an Oscar an Oscar for the joyride
fully artist yeah now it shall happen
congratulations this movie is delightful
I will watch it over and over thank you
thank you so much